you have ten dollars in your pocket and
you lose five what do you have in your
pocket the whole have a look at these
images what do we see we see items
ranging from food to garment electronic
devices to its accessory one more
observation would be that the prices of
these items are in the increasing order
okay that's cool
anything else that you notice look at
the pricing of these items keenly
strangely the price of every object here
ends with a number 9 have you ever
wondered why the price tags of almost
all the items that we encounter and with
the number 9 is there any reason behind
it let's find out there is a psychology
associated with the pricing of an item
and the price tags that end with number
9 is one among the pricing strategies
this strategy is commonly known as charm
pricing ever wondered why do companies
generally opt for charm pricing and why
do we fall for it so easily it's time to
find out
look at these two price tags here that
company deliberately chooses to keep
these prices instead of 150 rupees and
1,700 rupees is there any reason for
them to do so to our surprise there is
it's a trick
as customers with generally emotional
foods and this is clearly reflected when
it comes to shopping why do I say so
that's because while shopping when we
get attracted to any product we tend to
behave less rational or to be precise
our analytical skills drop down and due
to this mathematical blunders happen how
consider our example we generally
associate 149 rupees to spending one
hundred and forty rupees
similarly 1699 rupees to spending one
thousand six hundred rupees and does we
tend to feel that we're spending less
and the actual amount and eventually end
up buying the product all right now it
definitely might be thinking why don't
we associate 149 rupees to 150 rupees
and 1699 rupees to one thousand seven
hundred rupees well our brains take
shortcuts how whenever we look at any
number we usually tend to approach it
from the left to the right
take for instance 1699 rupees as we
approach the number from the left to the
right we register the first few digits
in our brain so strongly that we quickly
round up 1699 rupees to one thousand six
hundred rupees instead of one thousand
seven hundred rupees to make it more
concrete let's see two weeks later your
friend happens to ask for the price that
you paid for the item what would your
answer be I bet you would definitely say
the amount was somewhere around one
thousand six hundred rupees and not one
thousand seven hundred rupees
we do not realize but the fact is that
the difference between the actual price
and the amount we assume we've spent on
the item is close to 100 rupees another
interesting thing that companies do is
they allocate charm pricing under
specific brands look at these price
bands this can be seen more on
e-commerce websites let's say if a
product is priced at 500 rupees then it
automatically falls under the second
category of price band as seen here by
doing this chances are high that
companies might lose potential customers
who are looking under the first category
so if the product price is slightly
reduced by minimal amount say by one
rupee then it falls under the first
category of price band so it's a win-win
situation for both parties the customers
add the companies this signifies the
value of number nine so can we say that
number nine is really a magic number it
does look like that okay let's try
answering this question now where else
do we encounter charm pricing I want you
to think an answer that is correct
almost everywhere supermarkets retail
shops online streaming platforms food
outlets and the list seems to go on does
the moral of the story is that in more
competitive scenarios we generally tend
to encounter charm pricing strategy
we also tend to find prices like 181
rupees 57 rupees 63 rupees
what would they me is there any
psychological strategy behind it this is
your cue box to explore let us know your
interesting answers in the comment
section below to share this video with
your loved ones if you found it useful
be curious and happy learning
[Music]